whilst the world was still coming to
terms with the sheer level of
Devastation little boy and Fatman had
Unleashed on Japan over in Los Alamos
home of the Manhattan Project the
finishing touches were being made to
another atomic bomb had Japan not
surrendered to the Allies on the 15th of
August
1945 this third weapon was penell in for
being released over an unknown Japanese
City Just 4 days later nestled within
the C Center of this nuke that never
made it was a radioactive cord that had
been given the nickname Rufus history
has since given this 6.2 kg ball of
plutonium a different name this is the
story of the demon core a bomb that
killed despite never being
detonated